thanks for thanks for coming
you guys are are great partners and and
supporters of data Council so thank you
for that
um I want to jump right in and let you
introduce yourselves you could do it
better than I did
um and please tell us about the last job
that you had prior to getting into
Venture because I think that's
particularly interesting and might be
inspiring for for the other Geeks in the
room
I'm Slater excited to be here I'm a
partner at bcv focused uh on tools for
data teams for the most part
um I kind of had a halfway job before
this I led data at Valor equity which is
the growth stage investment firm but my
last kind of true data job was at square
or as a data scientist working mostly
with the growth team
hi everybody Lee Marie uh investing at
Founders fund been there for about two
years and look at devtools data and ml
really across all stages but but with a
particular focus on early stage uh part
of Founders fund I was one of the first
engineers at scale AI
um and then a product manager there and
was mostly working on building out lidar
annotation for self-driving cars and
other types of companies that use
perception hi hi I'm Lauren and uh I'm a
partner at Sequoia where I mostly focus
on early stage teams generally by
Engineers for engineers whether it's
data Engineers other Engineers of all
types
um I prior to Sequoia I was at segment
where I ran the core product team I was
there for about six years
um and then before that worked at a tiny
edtech startup that didn't go anywhere
that's about me great
so I think the the most common slide
I've seen hashed and rehashed and joked
about and teased is Matt Turks modern
Data stock or modern data ecosystem MDS
slide which now has umpteen trillion
logos on it and it's hard to track
um why are we here talking about
investing in data hasn't hasn't
everything already been built that needs
to be built and
um are there real gaps in this market
anymore
I mean my just as one take on this
um yeah I think there's definitely more
to do I don't
I guess it's framing like for Founders
maybe you know instead of taking the
magnifying glass and like finding some
space in the map that sort of you know
hasn't been taken over by this like
explosion of companies
um it's always not useful just to think
about problems that remain unsolved
which there are a ton of like unless we
feel as though we have no more problems
in data land
um and the other thing I'd say is like I
I think some stuff can be solved more or
solved better like we had olap free
snowflake like we had data
transformation pre-dvt so as long as
there are still problems to solve I
think there's more to do in data land
absolutely and I so one of the first
Market maps that I did I guess probably
really just a subset of the one that
keeps getting referenced but I just kept
hearing these pitches for data platform
and data tool and so I really needed to
map each tool to like what's the user
what's the use case and so I do think
there are always opportunities to make a
better X or to unbundle you know why or
to bundle z
um but yeah really focusing on the user
and the differentiation
um
got it
and what what mental model do you use to
sort of understand and categorize the
tools across this broader Market we have
many tool companies who participate in
data Council many who have grown up
through the ranks going from data
Council speaker to to founder how do you
sort of look at Matt's you know map and
how do you break it down in your head
into the meaningful car parts and
components for you Lauren I mean I think
about what problems they're solving for
customers I think similar to this later
and then we think about hey where do you
what's the base layer that everyone
needs to store their data and then what
do you need to do to understand it how
do you utilize it and think more from
the perspective of what is the problem
that you're solving then like hey I'm a
data observability tool like that can
solve a lot of different problems
and do you think that there's any like
specific gaps in this market like how
would you like are the things that are
on your short list
um outside of AI which we're going to
sort of save for later in the
conversation but
um you know specifically in the data
infrastructure tooling MDS sort of
analytics World
um or maybe even the machine learning
world as well because there's obviously
meaningful tooling being built there but
like what's on your short list in terms
of things that you're sort of actively
looking out for if a Founder came to
pitch you a company today like what's
missing from from your portfolio or for
what's a gap in your thesis that you
want to fill at this moment
I feel like people are less well served
today if you look at Tableau and looker
they've been stagnating for quite a
while and I think there's a new
generation of companies building
oh thank you
it's okay it's on now okay thank you
um I was just saying I think the top of
the stack actually is the least well
served did it like teams outside of the
data World
um and so building better tools to help
data teams serve their customers
um Tableau and looker have been around
for a really long time there's not much
that's happened there and I think as
we've built up more options the semantic
layer there's more to build on top of
those tools as well as
getting a little bit into AI uh there's
certainly new interfaces that can be
built on top of that data too
yeah I think sort of why now is always a
great question to ask and I mean I think
one theme that we've seen at the
conference the people are paying a lot
for snowflake um so as Slater said
earlier I think companies that promise
to sort of unbundle olap
um so like you know doc DB had a duck
DB's uh partner mother duck had a great
presentation yesterday on maybe we can
sort of use a duck DB query engine and
reduce costs and not have to send all
these queries to snowflake
um and then I think another great why
now gotta get into the ml stuff is this
the Advent of this llm technology and
how accessible it is can we rethink
parts of the data stack with that as a
first class Citizen and can that be sort
of a wedge into a different shaded
product
yeah I don't have time to add to that I
feel like it's what users or user groups
are like somewhat underserved or could
be better served and so like I agree
with Lauren's point that there's you
know like the business user is maybe
like a little bit less well served today
than like they were in the past which is
interesting I also think like the python
side of the ecosystem is still kind of
underserved relative to the SQL side so
some interesting things there right
there well let's stay at the top of the
stack for a minute because
um Lauren mentioned the applications
um you know that are being built now on
top of
um these tooling this this more
developed tooling it feels to me like
it's taken us kind of 10 years to get
here where we now have the data
etl'd and cleaned and transformed and
sitting in warehouses and it almost
feels to me like there's this next phase
of development where now we have to
figure out what to do with the data so I
mean I think reverse ETL is a little bit
of a manifestation of this right it's
not it's almost not its own category
it's that we realize that the data
pipeline actually extends to the right
of the data warehouse so now we get to
do all kinds of cool things with the
data and we never thought of that before
or weren't ready for it quite honestly
when you think about you know sort of
that as a framing or or even building on
top of snowflake what do you think about
this data Ops category like what does
that really mean and how do you sort of
suss out opportunities in that space in
terms of getting the user closer to end
users that might get a little bit
further and further away from the actual
infrastructure teams who who have done
all the etlings for the last little bit
I feel like
um
data applications is almost like two
different things in my head there's like
what I would call like the better than a
dashboard part which is like can I have
something that's more interactive I
could run some scripts on data I can
kind of do more than I could with kind
of like a purely passive dashboard and
then there's also this like internal Ops
use case which is like much more complex
and building something that an Ops team
is going to use internally it's going to
get used by like a fulfillment team or
like a sales team or something like that
and yeah they're really like just super
different with like different users
different buyers different problems to
solve like the right back problem
doesn't matter for the better than a
dashboard piece it matters a ton if
you're building internal applications so
I don't know I think of them as
different categories but I think they're
both valuable like both things that
should happen
yeah I agree I think we'll actually see
a huge expansion what it means to be a
data app I think the most basic data
apps so far have been analytics tools
dashboards and like a little bit more
complicated things for
um Ops teams but because building a
machine learning team and has been so
hard there hasn't been a whole lot of
apps with data to personalize them or
data to drive new features but now I
think that the bar has come down so much
for getting access to a lot of these uh
AI models whether it's large language
models or others
um I think we'll see a lot more
interesting functionality and data with
data in applications so it'll have
probably a whole different meaning in a
couple years
yeah I mean I love the the Paradigm of
now we have so much standardization in
the data stack you as an app can just
plug into the data warehouse and just
provide a lot of stuff out of the box
and especially a lot of stuff people
know SQL so yeah I think ml is an
exciting area like user analytics
experimentation just plug right into the
data stack um boarding time is super low
um sort of a little bit
um you know in conjunction with that or
opposed to that
um counter to that do you have a sense
that I think it might have been Tristan
handy who talked about the rebundling of
of analytics for instance and do you
have the sense that
um raw data sitting in inside these
systems that might be a little bit
harder to make use of coming out will
give way to more verticalized
applications like for instance I mean I
think the classic example is Google
analytics right and yeah it used to be
very easy for any of us
um even those who aren't technical to
sort of understand the conceptual
framework of web traffic and site
visitors because we had an idiot-proof
tool and ux that just walked us through
that now we're Landing all this raw data
and events and and stuff inside you know
generic horizontal scalable data stores
and to get the context out of that data
um you know with Tableau it's not might
not be the same experience obviously as
something that's as tightly baked as as
a ga so I'm wondering if you have
opinions on that and sort of which way
we're headed perhaps there
yeah I mean I think I think this
actually kind of goes back to Lauren's
point about like there was this business
user who was very happy with their 20
dashboards in GA or whatever set of
things they were looking at and I mean
I'm gonna just like pair it Tristan's
gospel on this because I think he's
right which is like that person has like
a worse experience now that everything
is gated by knowing SQL and knowing
where to find the tables and stuff like
that and so yeah I think there's an
interesting opportunity to like go look
at all of the verticalized analytics
that existed 10 years ago rebuild that
put it on top of the warehouse so you
actually have row level stuff because
like you know the thing that was
annoying about GA or other vertical
tools I felt like is
they worked great when you could answer
the question in the tool and then the
second that you couldn't and you just
wanted to have access to the underlying
data like it either didn't exist or you
couldn't get access to it it was very
gated in that way but I think you could
literally have both now where like it's
your own data since snowflake or your
Warehouse you can get at it but there is
a good story for the business user too
yeah I think the other benefit that you
get with the warehouse world is you have
contacts from a bunch of other data
sources and I think now that we're
rebuilding on top of that hopefully
we'll have much richer context with both
easy to use tools and customizable tools
well you mentioned machine learning use
cases and how some of that is advancing
our understanding and the way that we
sort of store and process data and we'll
we'll get to that but one one last
question
um which is you know a little clickbaity
a little a little important and
definitely top of mind on folks in this
room like our data contract's a thing is
this like some fresh magic or are we
really just talking about schemas like
which we've had forever any any hot
takes or opinions on this sort of world
of data contracts and and how hot it is
right now and Chad is here and has
joined us and
um I gave a talk which I wasn't able to
listen to unfortunately I'll catch the
recording but we have lots of thought
leadership around this area and I'm
curious
um in terms of your perspective as
investors how you sort of look at the
space
good reminder that data quality is still
a big challenge
um like we have all these tools that do
help out a lot but there's still kind of
this last Mile and just declaring a
schema maybe doesn't capture like all
the conversations between data consumers
and producers that need to happen
um and then maybe there is sort of a
useful level of abstraction where people
can you know test and make sure that
there aren't regressions estate is
coming in versus just thinking directly
um but yeah I mean I think it's an
exciting sort of take on data quality
and excited to see what tools come out
of it
cool well let's let's move on um into
some more of the the ml slash AI stuff
um Lee Marie you wrote a blog post which
seems like an eternity ago but it
reminded me it was only June of last
year
um you you sort of talked about your aha
moment when you had programmer friends
who told you that GitHub co-pilot was
actually something special and you might
have been a little bit incredulous prior
tell us about that moment what that
meant for you and sort of how you're
looking at the category now to kick us
off absolutely
um so yeah I think it was kind of a just
an aha moment in that when co-pilot
first came out alamed I was just very
skeptical I was like oh maybe this is
nice for people that are learning how to
code you know that it'll help auto
correct complete some of their words you
know that's great
um and then I'm catching up with a
portfolio company one that I can you
know consider having very strong
top-of-the-line engineering team they're
all using copilot
um and I was just blown away and they're
like you know we would we're using it
for free right now but we would pay you
know so much money if they decide if
they decided they're gonna just take it
away from us
um so I think that that was kind of the
start of I really need to understand
what this technology is capable of if
it's already capable of taking an A plus
programmer and like saving them I don't
know more than 25 of the time that they
spend writing code
um so really excited about things
especially in the devtool space I think
kind of given the success of co-pilot
there's a lot of adjacent areas
um where it becomes sort of very
feasible to unlock so like I have a
company uh that I'm working with called
regret where they essentially solve sort
of common Tech Deck Tech debt task right
out of the box so one thing that they
can do is like take your code base
that's written in JavaScript migrate it
to typescript and then the way that that
works it's an AI developer so it submits
a PR to your code base and then you're
commenting on that PR and an llm is
making those changes right so I think
that there's all these really cool
pockets of devtools
um where this just becomes yeah a 10x
better product than we could do before
um and then yeah I think unit testing is
another really cool area thinking about
how to just utilize this for Enterprises
whether it's like copilot on-prem
something that codium is doing another
portfolio company
um and then yeah let's see
all different types of code review you
can imagine like autocompleting DSL
um really really unlimited depth tools
possibilities
yeah it's very amazing that um the
coding and developer developer related
tooling has sort of been hit quickest um
by by the space
um and the developments of LMS obviously
there's also the other classic use cases
um Jasper's here this morning copy AI
um the sort of marketing generation you
know collateral which is obviously
catching on like wildfire also image
Generation
Um what other categories are we excited
about and we'll we'll spend time talking
about the dev tooling want to come back
to that I want to put a pin in that but
before we do that um what other sort of
high level spaces are you excited about
in terms of seeing the applications
technology
uh there are so many I feel like you can
just pick any application and this
technology will probably be able to
apply to it whether it's the language
model side whether it's image generation
or otherwise like you've got everything
from one that's very that I find
particularly fascinating is runwayml
which they work with film studios to do
the animation and production and you
just can film a video of yourself kind
of like once dancing around and it will
generate the background it will turn you
into whatever character you want to be
um they had a really interesting proof
point where they helped bring the design
team for the film everywhere everywhere
every anywhere everywhere all at once
um uh I think I still got it wrong
um uh from like 300 people down to seven
animators um using just their tool which
is an incredible proof of just how
effective it can be like watching that
film I did not know uh that it was any
different than what traditional
animation looks like
um so like there's there's creative
tools which I think is in a category
that was really unexpected to have ai
um have an impact in Beyond just the
general structured data that
that traditional ml has been able to
tackle I was later if you have others
yeah no I agree I mean I think there's a
ton right like there's all sorts of like
so many Industries are so like Document
Preparation oriented there's like a tons
of ton of things to do in like legal or
medical or you know all of these these
workflows that are very doc oriented but
I do think code is like the one that I
like think about the most because it's
just so many things or like one or two
degrees removed from like can I write
code to do this it's kind of the like
you know
um yeah like if software's eating the
world and AI is eating software like dot
dot dot like there will I think there'll
be a lot of like second order things
there too
and what do you think about
um the llm's replacing search use cases
I mean let's let's talk about that again
before we sort of stay high up before we
go deeper in the stock which I want to
get to but like is there existential
threat to to search based on chat GPT
absolutely
um yeah I mean so the sort of new
paradigm and I'm sure a lot of you have
seen I think the most mainstream example
of this now is being's new sort of chat
gbt uh interface but essentially it's a
new search experience you're talking
with somebody and they're giving you a
summary and you might not visit a web
page and so like traditional ads it's it
just doesn't work and traditional SEO
doesn't work you might like imagine a
world where you might pay to get your
data weighted more in this ml model that
ends up getting spent back out to you
um and so yeah I think it's something
that all of the big companies that are
involved in search are thinking about
heavily I thought this was really
interesting a few days ago I read Bing
has had one million new daily active
users just from the Bing preview
um and that to me I was I was kind of
surprised because
in some ways I do still like the
traditional search experience where I'm
getting to look through links and I'm
you know getting to sort of develop my
own opinion but then I talk to like my
parents or like you know some of my
friends and they love sort of the
experience of chatting with somebody and
so I yeah it's kind of unintuitive but
this sort of new paradigm is something
that a lot of people prefer over
traditional search
yeah I mean I think like information
retrieval will get like a ton better but
to your point like the most interesting
thing is like could could like the
entire Paradigm of search change because
like we're sort of search is built in
this time when it's like the the goal is
to like find docs that humans have
created like find resources that humans
have created as opposed to being able to
generate something so even again just
like going back to the coding use case I
find that like a lot of my old flow was
like I don't know how to solve this
problem I'm going to go search for
something on stack Overflow I'll like do
the synthesis in my head but now like
the AI can do the synthesis for me it's
just like tell me how to do this without
installing image magic right like
something else can do the thinking for
me which is interesting but I guess the
thing that worries me about this and I'm
glad you're brought up stock overflow
because it's so relevant to those of us
in this room like what about the death
of stack Overflow and so if we can
continue to go to the llms which sort of
were originally seeded with all this
great content from stack or quora or
wherever
um but but people stop going to those
sites to contribute for new developments
and new libraries and new things in the
future or like have we sort of you know
cut off our own our own nose despite our
face and we've relied on this ugc being
created for decades like 15 years anyway
um to support and to seed all these
Algos and is there some existential
crisis where you know we we sort of end
that process and there's there's no more
virtue of a virtuous content Loop
created I'm anyone concerned about that
or is it just me
yeah you can you can achieve immortality
by contributing to the training set
right like that's how you can you can uh
you can do that but I mean I I think
that like I mean I this is maybe like
going in a slightly different direction
but like I feel like I notice how a lot
of that stuff stopped becoming public a
few years ago like you have to be part
of some Discord or some slack group it's
not like a public subreddit stack
Overflow is still pretty public so I
mean interesting way I feel like I don't
know there's lots of different ways that
sort of like the Corpus of what's
available could change and like I don't
know having
a AI helped me mine like all of human
knowledge in some domain it feels like a
good
um uh that's the thing I want
I think in some ways
human intelligence is also generative
like we take in a bunch of contexts then
we think like we figure out how to draw
the connections between them and then
spit out and answer how the world works
let me test it against the real world
and if that's what these machine
learning models or llms are doing
themselves then it's not that different
from how we think so I think it's a
question of how good do they get because
I think at some point all content will
be generated and that's the world we're
going towards and if they're good enough
then like then we'll be great and if
they're not good enough then we'll just
have to keep generating our own content
too
yeah well one of the things I took away
from the the AI panel this morning
especially was
um the the the the quick the speed to
which every every panelist was really
wanting to talk about training on your
own data sets like we know already that
the llms you know they give us they sort
of rise the the floor you know maybe
they give you 80 utilization and sort of
a particular problem like right out of
the box but everyone kind of already is
already accepting that we need to be
able to whether it's prompt engineer
prompt engineering is not a real it's
not a real engineer by the way I didn't
know if you guys knew that
um whether it's prompt engineering or
fine-tuning or input processing or
output you know there's sort of these
ways that you can build utility coming
in and out of the model
um but obviously seeding it or or
training it um with our own data is
critical
um does does the no does the reality of
that change how you think about data
strategy and how you would encourage
your startups to be thinking about data
strategy G and how they might be
contributing to the future value chain
so to speak of how these AI models and
and systems will be be especially useful
I might actually disagree that prompt
engineering is not real engineering
because I think it's context Windows get
bigger it's like the only thing that you
can do that's different with your
interaction with an LM is the prompt
that you give it and as contact Windows
get bigger and there's more information
you can give to it you actually want to
be pretty careful and really thoughtful
about what information you do give so if
we're at the point down the line where
you can program some logic into what you
give a prompt that could be interesting
I don't know if that's what we'll end up
and right now yes prompt engineering is
generally very basic largely because
there's just not much you can give but
if we are in a future we can give more I
think it could be
much more interesting than it is today
but I'll let others answer the rest of
it and are you interested in companies
that simply wrap open API
no I mean well I think it needs to be
part of it I think it's part of the
picture but you also have the rest of
the product and the workflow and
everything else that someone interacts
with
um I think searches maybe like the
purest implementation of or product that
you can build after llm there's a few
others but most products will require
much more than just prompt engineering
on an lll
yeah it seems to me like we're still
exploring
um in in terms again of this the surface
area around the llm
um where does prompt engineering give
way to fine-tuning where does that give
way to oh I need my own bespoke model
and I should you know start from scratch
right I think I feel like we're still
turning the Dobbs the knobs and dials
and sort of figuring out like exactly
how we're going to extrapolate the value
that we need you know which brings up
the point that these llms are not really
like made to run at internet scale so
it's like what what other infrastructure
tooling
um you know since we're mostly tool
Builders here do we believe it's going
to emerge around the llm to sort of make
it you know internet ready internet
scale and and foolproof from an
application development standpoint what
are you what are you watching in that
category
yeah I guess
every company that I work with is like
thinking about this right now because I
think now is the time to honestly make
sure that you're recording the right
data that you need because you will
probably need to edit the current sort
of foundation model or whatever you end
up using
um whether it's fine tuning or you know
using something like a retro model this
is a really cool paper from deepmind
basically where you can create this
database of things to to teach your llm
and it will bring it into the prompt
depending on what's contextually
relevant but there's just so many like
different techniques so you can fine
tune something and and make it your own
and create a co-pilot for whatever
product that you're building
um and so yeah maybe something like a
vector database ends up being used to
store and like act on embeddings or
maybe there's like some other middle
layer that helps set a lot of this up
yeah I I feel like
um we'll eventually figure out how to
like separate the generative piece from
like the information retrieval piece and
like that will probably be the path
which people find ways of putting their
own data into the system and like you
know there's lots of interesting
approaches to that but like that
separation to me feels like the thing
where we don't want to store like all
this information like in the model ways
we want to like find some way of
separating those things out yeah we're
putting it all in your prompt seems It's
really challenging with like the current
version of yeah prompting
yeah it feels to me like we're still
like even though the the LMS are game
changing and again they sort of raise
the floor by by you know 80 percent
um the the fine-tuning loop is actually
looks a lot like the the same old ml Ops
Loop right of training your model your
bespoke model in the first place you
need clean data fresh data right labeled
data and so all the same things that
sort of go into the the fine-tuning loop
are basically things that we've been
discussing and we found a hard time with
quite honestly in the ml world over the
years so it seems to me like there might
be some miniaturization if you will of
the ml ops world that sort of becomes
the llm Ops World um do you agree or is
there something I'm missing there
I think something like that will happen
but like from a customer perspective I
feel like the closer to zero shot you
can get like the better experience it is
for that customer especially even if
it's a story where like later on you're
going to refine the model a little bit
like I I do think that like especially
if you're doing anything vertical
oriented like the closer to zero shot
you can get the better
and and what about the the plugins so we
should address the plugins because
they're so fresh and new and you know
I'm I'm still in the wait list I don't
know about you guys but
um like I I I had a question typed up
from last week to ask you guys like when
is open AI going to buy zapier before
after the conference and then they they
released the whole plug-in thing so I
can't even ask that question anymore
so um but but how how like this is like
the App Store of the iPhone like will
the impact be any less significant
I didn't realize you had written that
question before the launch
oh that's that's pretty good but it's
interesting because like so when I saw
the question you know I did actually
think about it even with the the plug-in
launch because oh maybe like zapier has
a ton of Integrations and but I do think
open AI seems to want to stay more on
the infrastructure side and so
theoretically we want to provide this
sort of technology to mini zap years so
zapier and then also sort of the L and
first staff ears that are that are being
built right now
um
but yeah I mean it does it definitely
shows that they are like continuing not
to just stay in the pure Foundation
model layer of the stack but starting to
move you know a layer up from that
yeah we had uh Sam Alvin come by our
office last week and he talked a bit
about plugins and
um one of the things that I think is not
to be underestimate is the open air is
incredibly ambitious and if you look at
the most valuable company it's not AWS
it's Apple it's the App Store and so he
they I think they will build where the
money is
um
but I think their their philosophy so
far has been to build what buildings
that are generally available for
everyone so they're not going to build
vertical Solutions on top of this most
likely
um but I think they're going to go for
wherever they think that the that they
can build the biggest business
well um we're essentially out of time
but uh in closing like address the
audience in a way that
um could give them some advice or help
or expertise right you you talk to a lot
of engineer Founders each of you every
week as do I and I'm sure there's
patterns and failure modes and common
pitfalls that you can advise folks
against like for the folks who are
thinking about taking the plunge and to
start a company what kind of advice
would you give them in parting
I feel like I'll say this sort of maybe
isn't theme but just like finding a real
problem that like remains unsolved is
like the core thing and it's also great
if you have some type of like fit for
that problem like there's some reason
why it should be you like that's one of
those things that's true like as a
fundamental and also true for like how
investors think about companies
um and then yeah I mean finally I feel
like moments of dislocation like having
new like this explosion of AI Tech are
always really interesting for Founders
because your advantage is nimbleness and
you there's probably all sorts of things
that are doable now that weren't doable
just like two years ago and it's an
exciting time
yeah that I agree with all that advice I
mean I think with engineer Founders in
particular I work with a ton of
technical Founders and I love it because
I you know I was an engineer
um
you know doubling down on what makes you
special and great I think is ultimately
like the main advice but then as you
grow your company having an open mind to
sort of people that can compliment you
not necessarily saying that you as a
Founder have to be great at everything
but you know I think some of the more
important hires that we made early on at
scale we hired a designer even before I
got hired and then we hired a
salesperson in our first 10 people
um and just having that complementary
expertise to compliment Alex who is an
excellent you know technical founder
um was huge and so that's that's
probably one common failure mode that I
see because you are so smart and I mean
I make the same mistake sometimes like
oh I can do it and I can learn it and I
can I know I know it but having that
sort of complimentary team with you yeah
I absolutely agree with all of that
um I think coming from the product world
one of the things that really matters
both I think for in product and for
Founders is to love what you're building
and love your customer like building a
company is an unreasonable thing to do
it is unreasonably hard you have to go
against this crazy competitive market
with these huge incumbents often and you
only are starting with you and a couple
people and a tiny bit of funding and so
in order to be able to make it through
you have to have be driven by something
Beyond just wanting to make money or be
rich and famous it has to be something
that you really love I believe
yeah well said thank you for that advice
well that concludes the panel enjoy your
afternoon folks and let's give the
panelists a hand
thank you
[Music]